vous ne pouvez pas éteindre un incendie
les yeux bandés c'est le plaidoyer du
directeur de l' oms en faveur du
dépistage massif
nous avons un message simple pour tous
les pays
tester tester tester tester tous les cas
suspects s'ils sont positifs
isolé lettre est trouvé avec les ont été
en contact deux jours avant qu'ils
développent leurs symptômes et tester
ces personnes haussier en corée du sud
ou en allemagne ou cinq cent mille tests
sont pratiqués chaque semaine la
stratégie semble être payante la france
essaye désormais de rattraper son retard
mais les tests restent encore réservé
aux patients sévèrement atteints ou
soignants présentant des symptômes trop
restrictif pour l'île de la réunion qui
a décidé de ne pas attendre sous la
pression des professionnels de santé
les autorités ont décidé de prendre des
mesures spécifiques
nous avons décidé d'aller au delà de
cette stratégie et des indications
retenu au plan métropolitain
deux facteurs nous amène à cette
décision
d'une part bien sûr l'insularité de la
réunion et un développement de
l'épidémie qui est en retard par rapport
à la métropole qui devrait nous laisser
bénéficier de leur expérience avec 800
tests quotidiens désormais les voyageurs
et des personnes contactent qui ont des
symptômes sont dépistés tout comme les
soignants même s'ils n'ont pas de
symptômes la méthode du drive test est
déjà opérationnelle avec notamment le
recours aux laboratoires privés la
martinique avec sa capacité de 50 est
actuellement ne semble pas faire preuve
du même empressement à la sortie du
confinement il est indispensable que
nous soyons doté de capacités de test
pour justement pouvoir lorsque les gens
vont recommencer à circuler éviter que
les personnes contaminées par le virus
soit potentiellement dangereuse pour les
autres pour l'instant les capacités de
l'automate qui existent au chu de la
martinique ne permet pas de faire ce
dépistage de masse à la capacité devrait
être grandement améliorée prochainement
avec la commande par la rs&de deuxième
ottomane
l'appui des laboratoires privés mais
certains politiques estiment qu'il ne
faut pas attendre la fin du confinement
et prennent les devants l'aer est de mon
point de vue fait une gestion zélé de la
pénurie qui est extrêmement dangereux
poule demain nous avons deux semaines de
retard par rapport à la croissance au
niveau de l'hexagone
il faut généraliser le dépistage comme à
la réunion engagé il ya une possibilité
déjà prévu dans le sud de la rivière
salée le maire de fort de france a pris
la décision d'organiser aussi un drive
dépistage ap en france et il faudrait
dans le nord caraïbe et dont le nom
atlantique il faut pas oublier avant une
règle de dépistage et aller le plus vite
possible parce que on a déjà une très
bonne nouvelle c'est que on pourra
utiliser la chloroquine c'est une
première chose mais pour utiliser après
donc la peur aucune des malades qui sont
pas encore au stade de thau spitz à dix
et il faut absolument qu'on puisse les
détecter en amont qui est malade qui est
porteur qui est sain une question que se
posent aujourd'hui près de 400000
martiniquais dont moins d'une centaine
est infecté officiellement